Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Netflix just released a new teaser trailer
and a bunch of previews for the Avatar
The Last Airbender live action series.
So we'll break it all down.
we have a pretty good idea for what
they're covering from the original series.
And since we've seen
how they treated the live action
one piece,
I think we all have a much better idea
of how they're approaching
the source material
and a lot more optimistic about it
in general
after the strong showing from one piece.
if you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for the series
once it does premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll probably do a fun avatar giveaway
when that actually starts.
they're going to release
a much bigger trailer in a couple weeks.
They'll probably announce
a loose release date
and whatever kind of trailer that winds up
being like spring or summer next year.
My bet is on summer around the same time
that one piece premiered this past year,
like July or August,
this is the official logo.
And using the live action
one piece as a benchmark,
I'll say that also changed
the original avatar intro,
but also do something similar to that
with the four elements
with voiceover narration from Katara.
they change the one piece intro
because it was so long.
The Avatar intro isn't quite as long,
but it's also a pretty long intro,
so during the first episode,
they'll probably like the full intro
with the back story,
like the day the Fire Nation attacked
basically explained the 100 year war,
how it wound up in the eyes,
what happened with the fire nation
attacking the rest of the world.
then probably from episode two
for the rest of the season,
they'll just do the much quicker logo
only intro with their version.
The four elements on screen,
like a much quicker version of the intro
for all the other episodes the whole idea
with the tarp burning here with the logo,
you can see the cinders
floating in the background.
It's meant to depict the fire nation
attacking as in the war itself.
most of the actual scenes
that they just previewed
this past day were for the Fire Nation.
Main characters
like the trailer only has the fire nation
symbol burning in the rock with the logo.
I don't know if that means
that the next teaser trailer
they released in a couple of weeks
will just be for the Fire Nation.
Or they're only doing the Fire Nation
preview.
Then they'll save everybody else
for a later trailer.
but the first big one is Zuko,
played by Dallas Liu.
He actually just starred in Marvel's
Shang Xi movie a couple of years ago.
He played Katie's brother,
so it was a pretty quick scene.
this scene from Avatar
that they're previewing here
is from early in the season.
And he's on his military ship in exile
with Iroh looking for the avatar.
I must find the avatar.
is always funny to hear Dante Basco
doing all the Avatar memes.
Like he'll recite some of the lines
every time he does convention appearances.
Of course, I must capture
the avatar, regain my order.
All day, every day,
similar lines have become names
and phrases.
Hello, Zuko Hair.
so many iconic Zuko lines.
zoom and enhanced in the background.
The shrine here is actually Iroh's
Son Lu ten,
who died during Iroh's 600 days
siege of Ba Sing Se
during the last years of the 100 year war,
the siege was unsuccessful, mostly
because Iroh learned of his son's death
he lost all will to fight
and no longer cared
about becoming the next firelord,
succeeding his
and using his father as a line.
We see Iroh and one of the other scenes.
I'll talk about him in a second,
don't worry,
because he actually does look pretty good.
Zuko's military uniform is exactly like
it was in the animated version
during season one.
He looks pretty accurate too.
I was curious
to see how they portray his scar
just because
it's such a big part of his character.
this doesn't look quite as big
as it does in animation,
but I think it looks pretty decent.
We'll see when we get some actual footage.
His haircut also looks very similar
to the reason
why he eventually changed his hair cut
and let it grow out
was that he could disguise himself
during book two.
Generally from the look of everyone's
costumes.
It does look like Netflix actually
spent some money to do the costumes right
instead of keeping it out.
So I am happy about that. behind him.
You can see all the maps
they use on his ship
to find their way around the world
looking for the avatar.
Even though Ayano himself doesn't
really care about finding the avatar like.
Yeah, yeah, sure Zuko, whatever.
We'll look for the avatar.
Who cares
all the sides of the ship are metal.
You can see the rivets here.
Like all the Renaissance
ships are made of metal.
Then next is Uncle Iroh.
He's played by Paul
Sun Lee, who you probably recognize
from The Mandalorian,
Asoka Kim's convenience.
he's actually named Appa
on Kim's convenience.
So we have an oppa now next to the actual
Appa on Avatar The Last Airbender
This is a completely different scene
that he's in.
He looks like he's visiting
Zuko or somebody else
or the avatar behind bars on land.
He's smiling,
but that doesn't actually mean much
because Iroh's
usually in a very pleasant mood, no matter
what kind of crazy stuff is going down,
like even in the middle of a big fight,
he always has some sage wisdom, like,
Why don't you have some tea?
Let's all just chill out, have some tea
The main
reason why he left the fire nation
capital with Zuko when he was exiled
was mostly to look after him.
Because after his son Lu ten died, Zuko
kind of became
like a surrogate son to him.
And he became more like a father to Zuko
than firelord Ozai ever was like violent.
Was I probably one of the worst dads
in all of media even though
during the events of book one
or what's going to be the events of season
one of the live action show, Zuko hasn't
really admitted that fully to himself.
one of the terms of Zuko's
exile was that he could come back
if he found the avatar.
So he is absolutely obsessed, obsessed
with finding the avatar,
even though the truth of the matter
is that I actually think it's
better for him that they left the capital
like you need
to get away from your father.
Otherwise you're going to wind up
turning into an even worse version of him.
So Iroh is treating their exile
like a really glorified vacation.
Like now let's have fun. Who cares
if we find the avatar?
they also sought to hint at him
being part of the White Lotus and actually
being one of the allies of the avatar
a little bit during the season.
Because once Zuko actually
does almost briefly capture the avatar
you can kind of tell that Iroh
is really on board with Zuko's plan
to bring him back to the fire.
Lord, like,
how about we possibly not do that
and then just chill
out, have some tea together?
Zuko probably has one
of the best redemption arcs of all time.
Season one, though, is like him
at the beginning of that.
So he's like Zero Chill.
Zuko Iroh spends most of his time
trying to get him to forget about
the avatar and start enjoying his life.
It's not really till like well into book
two that he slowly starts to do that.
Like it takes a while for that to set in
the whole idea is that Iroh was born
the eldest son.
He was the original crown
prince of the fire nation,
and until the death of his son,
he acted like
he behaved like the dutiful fire nation
prince who would be firelord someday.
He was a great general in their army,
but then basically gave
that all up and kind of became a pacifist
after the death of his son.
So Ozaki conspired behind his back
to get their father fire
Lord Aslan, to name him the actual heir.
speak of the Devil.
This is firelord Ozai.
He's played by Daniel Dae Kim.
Most of you might remember him
from previous Avatar roles
like he was on both series.
He was General Fong during the original
Avatar The Last Airbender series,
and then during Legend of Korra,
he played Asami, his father, Hiroshi Sato.
so this is like full circle, coming
back to the original series for him.
Like he's a huge star now,
so it's a pretty easy
slam dunk casting him as those I like.
of course
we would bring him back for this.
he looks fantastic.
He's going to be a great overarching
villain for like the entire series
For those of you that did not watch
the original animated avatar, The Last
Airbender, Mark Hamill was actually
the voice of the original fire.
Lord Ozai.
during his seen here.
He looks like he's reading a war map,
part of their current military campaigns.
When Susan's comet eventually comes,
the fire nation will reach its peak
level of power, making him all
but unkillable to anyone but the avatar.
during the scene, he's
inside the Fire Nation Palace throne room.
But those are the same fires behind
the throne from the animated series.
His robes
look exactly like they firelords.
Customary rose from the original series.
Each firelord wears mostly the same robes
Zuko wears them to when he becomes fire.
Lord, This is the firelord's headpiece.
That's like their version of a crown.
Each firelord wears it.
Even Zuko eventually,
next big character is a Zula herself,
one of the best villains in animation
she's played by Elizabeth Yu.
I haven't seen a lot of her other stuff
before.
This is like
the biggest thing that she's done so far.
you just have to imagine
the casting director
looking for someone who can pull off
like the entire range of crazy.
Like most of the time.
Early on, Azula is depicted as this cold,
calculating character,
and by the very end of the story,
she has gone
full blown
crazy pants like dial it up to 110%.
get her in that insane asylum.
it is going to be so much fun
watching her torment all the characters
from the majority of the show.
Then to see her
completely fly off the deep end.
just in terms of power level.
She starts out being way
more powerful in practice
than Zuko, like she has crazy
natural talent in fire bending.
She is a fire bending prodigy.
That's why her fire is blue flame,
not regular flame.
she also starts out the series already
knowing how to Lightning Bend.
Zuko eventually learns
how to do those things,
but Iroh has to teach him
how to Lightning Bend.
Later in the series, last big scene
they're previewing here is of Commander
Zhao,
who's one of the other main antagonists
in the first arc of the show,
like book one, season one
I don't really count Zuko
as an antagonist,
but that's kind of how he starts out
at the very beginning of the series.
Really.
It's Commander Zhao
that's the main villain of season one.
Like he winds up
taking over the search for the Avatar
after he learned Zuko and Iroh found him,
tells them to the northern water tribe
where he lay siege to the city becomes
more of a rival to Zuko
because he wants to promotion
to the rank of general in the glory
of bringing the avatar back to power.
Lord knows, instead of letting Zuko do it,
which also starts to set
Zuko down the path of being the Avatar's
ally during season one.
Like the whole Blue Spirit Mask event
hiding himself, he doesn't actually
start out calling himself the Blue spirit
either till like later in the series.
they've not released
all the episode titles yet,
or exactly how they're breaking
book one up.
And if there's going to be three seasons
of the show for three books,
or if they'll just split
some of the books up into multiple seasons
like we're making all these one piece
live action comparisons.
But there is like years
and years of one piece material for them
to adapt to episodes.
There's not that much material
from the original Avatar
The Last Airbender series.
They'll probably do the same thing
they did for one piece, Season one,
where they changed some stuff
from the original source material,
but for the most part
they try to be as accurate as possible.
So expect them to move a couple of things
around and add a couple extra scenes
that weren't in the original version.
like they might make Azula and Ozaki
bigger characters during season one.
But I do think they'll be accurate in that
they'll wait till season two
to introduce the Toph character,
there's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
They're also doing some one piece stuff
at this upcoming Netflix event
where they're dropping the Avatar
The Last Airbender trailer,
but they're not really ready to release
season two yet.
Like, they literally
just started working on it again
because the writers strike ended.
I just did a one piece season
two teaser trailer video,
so I'll link that below in the description
and at the end of this.
but the other big reminder
is that Invincible Season two
episodes will start in a couple of weeks.
I'll be doing episode videos for that.
So animation fans will be eating
really good in the next year or two
Mike and Bryan's Avatar
The Last Airbender movie
isn't going to premiered
to like 2025 though,
so it'll be a good long while before
we actually see some footage from that.
They're also working on a brand
new Avatar The Last Airbender series
based on like the Next Earth
Bender Avatar
After Korra.
So we'll find out
more about that soon to click here
for the other brand new Avatar
The Last Airbender
trailer is a little bit longer
and click here for that one piece.
Season 2 Teaser Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!